we all saw the gruesome pictures from
bucha and other areas from which russian
troops have recently left
yesterday i conveyed to president
zielinski my condolences
and assured him of the european
commission's full support in these
terrible times
these atrocities cannot and will not be
left unanswered
the perpetrators of these heinous crimes
must not go unpunished
the european union has set up a joint
investigation team with ukraine
its task is to collect evidence and
investigate war crimes and crimes
against humanity in ukraine
russia is waging a cruel and ruthless
war not only against ukraine's brave
troops
but also against its civilian population
it is important to sustain utmost
pressure on putin and the russian
government at this crucial point
the four packages of sanctions have hit
hard
and limited the kremlin's political and
economic options
we're seeing tangible results
but clearly in view of events we need to
increase our pressure further
so today we are proposing to take our
sanctions a step further
we will make them broader
and sharper so that they cut even deeper
into the russian economy
this fifth package has six pillars
first
we will impose an import ban on coal
from russia worth 4 billion euros per
year
this will cut another important revenue
source for russia
second a full transaction bank on four
key russian banks among them vtb the
second largest russian bank
these four banks which we now totally
cut off from the markets
represent 23 percent of market share in
the russian banking sector
this will further weaken russia's
financial system
third
a ban on russian vessels and
russian-operated vessels from accessing
eu ports
certain exemptions will cover essentials
such as agriculture and food products
humanitarian aid as well as energy
additionally we will propose a ban on
russian and bella russian road transport
operators
this span will drastically limit the
options for russian industry to obtain
key goods
fourth
further targeted export bans worth 10
billion euros in areas in which russia
is vulnerable this includes for example
quantum computers and advanced
semiconductors
but also sensitive machinery and
transportation equipment
with this we will continue to degrade
russia's technological base and
industrial capacity
fifth
specific new import bans worth 5.5
billion euros
to cut the money stream of russia and
its oligarchs on products from wood to
salmon from seafood to liquor
in doing this
we also close loopholes between russia
and belarus
sixth
we take a number of very targeted
measures such as a general eu ban on
participation of russian companies
in public procurement in member states
or an exclusion of all financial support
being a european national to russian
public bodies
because european tax money should not go
to russia in whatever shape or form
finally
we are also proposing further listings
of individuals which hrvp joseph burrell
will explain to you
but this is not all
we're working on additional sanctions
including on oil imports
and we are reflecting on some of the
ideas presented by the member states
such as taxes or specific payment
channels such as an escrow account
today more than 40 countries apply
sanctions like these
to take a clear stand
is not only crucial for us in europe but
also for the rest of the world
a clear stand against putin's war of
choice
a clear stand against the massacre of
civilians
and a clear stand against the violation
of the fundamental principles of the
world order
slava ukrainia
the european union's position has been
very clear
we will continue to advance the
sanctions as long as the russian
aggression continues
where today is submitting proposal for
more sanctions
to further [ __ ] putin's war machinery
following the atrocities committed by
the russian armed forces in bukka
and other places under russian
occupation in ukraine
we continue to follow with horror the
brutal siege of mario paul
and his haunting images of large number
of civilian deaths and casualties
and destruction of civilian
infrastructures
desires to reports
of inhuman and degrading treatment by
the russians occupation forces on the
civilian population in ukraine
they show the true face
of this war the war of claiming against
ukraine and its people
and we are now proposing for the council
approval
to scale up bans on certain exports
including technologies and jet fuel
include also banning imports of goods
which provide significant revenue to the
state budget
prohibiting imports of
some fuels particularly coal
proposing further financial measures and
prohibiting russian vessels from
entering european union boards the
president of the commission
has elaborated on detail on these
sectoral sanctions
from my side let me explain that we are
also standing the sanctions list
adding dozens of people from politics to
business sector and engage in propaganda
activities
and also more entities from financial
military industrial and transport
sectors
and among them four important banks
russian ban that will not only be taken
out of the swift system but also
forbidden of taking any kind of activity
and participating in any kind of
transactions inside the european
union again
we are not targeting russian people
we are targeting the kremlin the
political and economic elites
the ones who are supporting putin's war
in ukraine
the aim of our sanctions is to top the
reckless inhuman and aggressive behavior
of the russian troops
and to make clear to the decision makers
in the kremlin that their illegal
aggression comes at a heavy cost
we are also taking other steps in
reaction to the murderous behavior by
the kremlin and its troops
the russians illegal and disruptive
actions against the interest and
security of the european union and
european union member estates
including breaching the 1961 vienna
convention on diplomatic relations
are not staying without us firm response
and that's why today i decided to
designate persona non grata
a number of officials of the permanent
missions of the russian federation to
the european union
for engaging in activities contrary to
their diplomatic status
the external election service of the
european union the secretary general
it's morning the russian ambassador to
the european union today
to communicate this decision